toute la journée on lui a rendu visite
comme on rend visite
un grand blessé c'est un peu comme quand
un proche a eu un accident on valoir à
l'hôpital
et puis on revient le lendemain voir
comment il va
les parisiens sont venus aux nouvelles
inquiet consterné tout le long de la
seine sur les deux rives et les
boulevards adjacent des centaines de
petit écran ont capté ce qui reste de la
cathédrale notre dame de paris
effectivement les dégâts maintenant
paraissent moins grave que ça n'aurait
pu l'être ce qu'on a vraiment hyper
qu'elle s'effondre
là elle est là dans toute sa grandeur
mais les dégâts sont énormes le toit
certaines vitres ou et cette flèche
majestueuse qui servait de repaire aux
parisiens complètement perdu la flèche
elle contenait de 3,3 roenick lépine une
épine de la couronne du christ une
relique de sainte geneviève qui est
patronne de paris est une relique de
saint denis
et ça c'était c'était dans la flèche qui
s'enflamment et voilà c'est parti
car pour ces dames ému c'est peut-être
aussi la fin d'une époque
il paraît qu'on pourra pas rentrer ni la
reconstruire avant des années - l'âge
que j'ai à l'âge que nous avons
peut-être qu'on pourra plus jamais y
rentrer lissa elle qui a grandi en
regardant notre dame de la fenêtre de
son lycée pense à la prochaine
génération
j'aurais aimé que mes enfants il avoué
norman avait pas de ça va arriver non ça
y est là
au même si même s'ils font des
constructions et tout sera plus jamais
pareil je pense
[Musique]
et c'est un incendie qui aurait
probablement pu être évitée didier
rykner journaliste à la tribune de l'art
ce que je sais en tout cas c'est que un
monument sur deux qui brûle en france
entre ministres qu'ils veulent c'est dû
à des actions de chantier ça c'est un
fait et j'ai pu lord enquête que j'ai
menées et j'ai fait des articles voir
qu'il y avait qu il n'y avait pas
suffisamment de mesures drastiques de
sécurité pour les monuments y avait-il
dit gicleurs suffisamment de détecteurs
de fumée l'enquète ne fait que commencer
mais déjà c'est un président français
optimiste qui a fait une grande promesse
à ce que ce soir nous rebâtirons la
cathédrale notre-dame plus belle encore
et je veux que cela soit achevé d'ici
cinq à mais nous le pouvons encourager
surtout par l'incroyable élan de
générosité qui se manifeste en moins de
24 heures déjà des centaines de millions
d'euros ont été promis par des grandes
sociétés des mécènes pour assurer cette
reconstruction
donc maintenant on va on va tous
participé financièrement parce que tout
le monde se voit là va essayer de lever
des fonds chacun à notre niveau
ce soir les français sont unis dans la
rue de toutes origines et tout âge
ils ont défilé en prière pour se rendre
encore une fois au chevet de leur
cathédrale
[Musique]
oh